the reason for the Ovation here and the
stumble is because Arch Manning has just
made his Texas debut he hadn't played
all year the fans have been waiting for
this and he's finally in the game he
hands it off on his first snap your
leader of this program he's got it all
here's his first college pass or no
going to take off that CR goes nuts well
ball on the ground and it's still loose
Manning able to get on it at the 18 y
there it
is Manning getting out of trouble
keeping it staying in bounds and now
scooting out of play after all the
threats to being tossed out of the
booth man oh boy there's the arm Talent
on display completing it to
cook and jont cook a fellow true
freshman 14 years and still being a
position play for the national
championship they got a conversion with
Manning